while conservative leaf supporters have
been pretty up in arms against the Prime
Minister's plan many have vowed to vote
against it one of them is the former
Northern Ireland Secretary Theresa
Villiers who joins us now thank you for
being on the show so you've said that
you're going to be voting against the
prime ministers deals what do you want
to happen you know the EU needs to give
us a better deal I think there's still
time for the prime minister to ask for a
better deal without this backstop
without the unconditional payment of 38
billion but ultimately if the EU are
going to be unreasonable then we must be
prepared to leave without a full
withdrawal agreement and make a clean
break exit we just heard from circus Tom
the shadow brexit secretary he says that
no du would be like going off a cliff I
think there's a huge amount of
exaggeration and fear-mongering about
the idea of leaving without withdraw
agreement yes there would be disruption
but only if the EU is determined to be
uncooperative trading on World Trade
Organization terms and most favored
nation status is the basis on which
countries around the world do business
and indeed the EU itself does business
in a perfectly sort of smooth and
orderly manner with many trading
partners on that basis so it can do that
with us
at same time though it isn't not a bit
too easy to be slightly blase about what
that disruption would mean I mean we've
been reading about new formula milk for
babies for example being held up in the
Port of Dover Bank of England warning
that it would have a crash worse than
what happened in 2008 I mean this is
quite alarming this well I good it's not
the best outcome I wish I hope we don't
come to that I hope the EU sees reason
but there are ways to manage this to
minimize the disruption I have pressed
the government repeatedly on this they
have done a great deal of no deal
preparation and it is vital that they
use the next three months as effectively
as possible to take every possible
unilateral step to minimize any
potential disruption and inconvenience
but there is no doubt that the the
medium and long term benefits of
regaining control over the way we
regulate our economy and our trade
policy far
outweigh any disadvantages in the short
term of leaving and actually the Bank of
England sort of debate an and statement
about you know equivalence with the 2008
crash the governor actually was on on
the radio saying that's not the likely
outcome that was just one of a number of
scenarios the bank looked at in a
worst-case scenario he's not actually
predicting that that is what he's going
to happen at the same time there could
be a recession they can limit that if
that was what was predicted to occur
after the lis folks and it didn't that
was what was predicted after the UK
declined to join the Europe the same
time we'll have more things will change
after a No Deal if you look at the
Treasury forecasts they underestimate
the benefits of new trade agreements
they massively overestimate the costs of
customs compliance and also in some
instances that they they don't actually
take into account any of the behavior
change by the government or individuals
which which will involve adapting to a
new situation so there's simply not a
realistic picture of what what would
happen but yes there would be some
disruption but only if the EU wants to
behave in an unreasonable way they are
under WTO rules obliged to cooperate
with trading partners they shouldn't
treat us less favorably than other third
countries if they choose to do that then
there will be disruption but it is in
breach of their international legal
obligations if tourism a can't get her
deal through Parliament which looks
relatively likely with a number of
conservative MPs who speaking out
against it don't you need to stand down
I don't think the the leadership is the
the big issue I think we need to change
the approach we need to change the
policy rather than the person so if this
agreement is voted down the Prime
Minister should go back to Brussels to
make it clear that the the draft
agreement that was reached is not
accepted and it's not going to go
through Parliament and it's in
everybody's interest to have an
agreement without this unnecessary
backstop arrangement and an agreement
which makes payment to the EU
conditional on progress on reaching our
future trade arrangement and economic
partners so to confirm you haven't
submit
a letter of no-confidence in tourism oh
no haven't no and how would she vote in
a confidence nation I think it would
depend on the circumstance in the
government if there was a confidence
resolution in relation to the Prime
Minister I would have to look at the
circumstances at the time but you know
my present intention would be to vote to
have confidence in the Prime Minister
and then just finally and we've been
talking a lot this morning about the
legal advice that the government has
been given on brexit whether or not they
should have to publish it what's your
position do you think that the
government should publish the full legal
advice that is received
I support the government's position on
this it's an entirely exceptional for
legal advice ever to be published the
government needs to be able to get free
and frank legal advice which it doesn't
have to disclose there has obviously
been this vote in Parliament and I think
the government's proposal to publish a
summary of their legal advice is is
compliant with that resolution okay miss
Villiers thank you very much